what do you say your personal life's in
a funnel cake of [ __ ] uh
how are you doing now
well it's been crazy man like um
um you know i was doing this saturday
sobriety session doing all the [ __ ] for
sobriety i went to s known i went to
rehab got sober i did the song um uh
twin lakes uh ready for recovery it's a
great record yeah thank you man thank
you and and you know even people that
like don't understand that record
there's there's so many people that do
that make it so worth it you know what i
mean
i i get it to this day um
and i did a great job man you know it's
it says same though but it's that
alcoholic attic [ __ ] you know you start
thinking you're cocky enough to like
really no i got this you know you [ __ ]
up you know so i relapsed i was probably
like a year and a half or even more
almost close to two years sober
relapse gotten some
terrible [ __ ] to happen and then you
know i've just been in the situation and
with corona
you know with the covert [ __ ] and us um
you know quarantining and just being
stuck you know it's been a [ __ ]
but right now i'm feeling back on my
feet i'm you know i mean so it's getting
better
it's getting better but a lot of fans
don't understand and the same thing
that's what i'm about you know i want to
be real with the fans and nobody ever
asked me you know real [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying that's what it
is you know picture perfect came out
um
you know that was cool celebrated the
christmas album came out and life went
went crazy it was just like waiting to
get back on tour again you know well you
know what's crazy is like you always
talk about like them you you touched on
this in your music like the
misconception
that you're like a rich guy
yeah yeah and like financially you've
had issues yeah and and you know what i
get that all the time like it's i'm
happy you asked me that because i get
that all the time like these guys man
you broke ass [ __ ] it's like
telling some guy like these glasses are
ten dollars and then they they're like
oh thank you so much and they go order
ten pairs and then they say that's what
you get for working them ten dollars
classes so you can't use that against me
bro you don't know my life you know also
yeah you you're very transparent yeah
very transparent and my and i want to be
transparent right now i've had some
money
here's the thing man to everybody who's
out there who's working who's an artist
who i've watched bootleg kev interview
period and and y'all might not even know
the [ __ ] i am or respect what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about either way let me tell
you something
a hundred thousand dollars is a hundred
dollars
two hundred thousand it all goes away
next thing you know to be all gone
you'll be happy to get five hundred
dollars you gotta be careful man you
know what i'm saying and it's not you
blow and it's not like you're blowing it
all on jewelry and no crazy [ __ ] it's
life man you start thinking you're
you're the big [ __ ] you got to be
consistent and hell all of us know right
now [ __ ] a [ __ ] pandemic can come
and how much did that cost you
oh my god dude i mean i didn't work bro
and like because you you do so much live
live shows i do i didn't work so like
before that happened i was already you
know in debt from
doing what i was doing and and then i
started a label you know when you when
you start a label you get an advance you
know you do all that but either way man
yeah it [ __ ] me up i mean if you got
an artist that tours right if if
everybody doesn't know me as a household
name or on the radio or what or whatever
um
yeah man it's not like you're making a
shitload of money most of your money
comes from touring